because they say they're too concrete, they're disconnected from the world.
But, we've even had that here on stage,
so don't act like you don't know what I'm talking about.
(Laughter)
We had folks talking about the Flat Earth Society
and flower arrangers,
so there's this whole dichotomy
that we continue to carry along, even when we know better.
And folks say we need to choose either-or.
But it would really be foolish to choose either one,
intuitive versus analytical.
That's a foolish choice.
It's foolish just like trying to choose between being realistic or idealistic.
You need both in life.
Why do people do this?
I'm going to quote a molecular biologist, Sydney Brenner,
who's 70 years old, so he can say this.
He said, "It's always important to distinguish between chastity
and impotence."
Now --
(Laughter)
I want to share with you a little equation, OK?
How does understanding science and the arts fit into our lives
and what's going on
and the things we're talking about here at the design conference?
And this is a little thing I came up with:
understanding
and our resources and our will
cause us to have outcomes.
Our understanding is our science, our arts, our religion;
how we see the universe around us;
our resources, our money, our labor, our minerals --
those things that are out there in the world we have to work with.
But more importantly, there's our will.
This is our vision,
our aspirations of the future, our hopes, our dreams,
our struggles and our fears.
Our successes and our failures influence what we do with all of those.
And to me, design and engineering, craftsmanship and skilled labor,
are all the things that work on this to have our outcome,
which is our human quality of life.
Where do we want the world to be?
And guess what?
Regardless of how we look at this,
whether we look at arts and sciences as separate or different,
they're both being influenced now and they're both having problems.
I did a project called S.E.E.ing the Future:
Science, Engineering and Education.
It was looking at how to shed light
on the most effective use of government funding.
We got a bunch of scientists in all stages of their careers.
They came to Dartmouth College, where I was teaching.
And they talked about, with theologians and financiers:
What are some of the issues of public funding
for science and engineering research?
What's most important about it?
There are some ideas that emerged
that I think have really powerful parallels to the arts.
The first thing they said was that the circumstances
that we find ourselves in today in the sciences and engineering
that made us world leaders
are very different than the '40s, the '50s, and the '60s and the '70s,
when we emerged as world leaders,
because we're no longer in competition with fascism,
with Soviet-style communism.
And by the way, that competition wasn't just military;
it included social competition and political competition as well,
that allowed us to look at space as one of those platforms
to prove that our social system was better.
Another thing they talked about was that the infrastructure
that supports the sciences
is becoming obsolete.
We look at universities and colleges --
small, mid-sized community colleges across the country --
their laboratories are becoming obsolete.
And this is where we train most of our science workers
and our researchers -- and our teachers, by the way.
And there's a media that doesn't support the dissemination of any more than
the most mundane and inane of information.
There's pseudoscience, crop circles, alien autopsy, haunted houses,
or disasters.
And that's what we see.
This isn't really the information you need to operate in everyday life
and figure out how to participate in this democracy
and determine what's going on.
They also said there's a change in the corporate mentality.
Whereas government money had always been there
for basic science and engineering research,
we also counted on some companies to do some basic research.
But what's happened now is companies put more energy
into short-term product development
than they do in basic engineering and science research.
And education is not keeping up.
In K through 12, people are taking out wet labs.
They think if we put a computer in the room,
it's going to take the place of actually mixing the acids
or growing the potatoes.
And government funding is decreasing in spending,
and then they're saying, let's have corporations take over,
and that's not true.
Government funding should at least do things
like recognize cost benefits of basic science and engineering research.
We have to know that we have a responsibility as global citizens
in this world.
We have to look at the education of humans.
We need to build our resources today to make sure that they're trained
so they understand the importance of these things.
And we have to support the vitality of science.
That doesn't mean that everything has to have one thing that's going to go on,
or that we know exactly what's going to be the outcome of it,
but that we support the vitality and the intellectual curiosity
that goes along [with it].
And if you think about those parallels to the arts --
the competition with the Bolshoi Ballet spurred
the Joffrey and the New York City Ballet to become better.
Infrastructure, museums, theaters, movie houses across the country
are disappearing.
We have more television stations with less to watch,
we have more money spent on rewrites
to get old television programs
in the movies.
We have corporate funding now that,
when it goes to support the arts,
it almost requires that the product be part of the picture
that the artist draws.
We have stadiums that are named over and over again by corporations.
In Houston, we're trying to figure out what to do with that Enron Stadium thing.
(Laughter)
Fine arts and education in the schools is disappearing,
And we have a government that seems like it's gutting the NEA
and other programs.
So we have to really stop and think:
What are we trying to do with the sciences and the arts?
There's a need to revitalize them.
We have to pay attention to it.
I just want to tell you quickly what I'm doing --
(Applause)
I want to tell you what I've been doing a little bit since ...
I feel this need to sort of integrate some of the ideas
that I've had and run across over time.
One of the things that I found out is that there's a need to repair
the dichotomy between the mind and body as well.
My mother always told me, you have to be observant,
know what's going on in your mind and your body.
And as a dancer, I had this tremendous faith in my ability to know my body,
just as I knew how to sense colors.
Then I went to medical school,
and I was supposed to just go on what the machine said about bodies.
You know, you would ask patients questions and some people would tell you,
"Don't listen to what the patient said."
We know that patients know and understand their bodies better,
but these days we're trying to divorce them from that idea.
We have to reconcile the patient's knowledge of their body
with physicians' measurements.
We had someone talk about measuring emotions
and getting machines to figure out what to keep us from acting crazy.
No, we shouldn't measure.
We shouldn't use machines to measure road rage
and then do something to keep us from engaging in it.
Maybe we can have machines help us to recognize that we have road rage,
and then we need to know how to control that without the machines.
We even need to be able to recognize that without the machines.
What I'm very concerned about is:
How do we bolster our self-awareness as humans, as biological organisms?
Michael Moschen spoke of having to teach
and learn how to feel with my eyes, to see with my hands.
We have all kinds of possibilities to use our senses by,
and that's what we have to do.
That's what I want to do --
to try to use bioinstrumentation, those kind of things,
to help our senses in what we do.
That's the work I've been doing now,
as a company called BioSentient Corporation.
I figured I'd have to do that ad, because I'm an entrepreneur,
and "entrepreneur" says "somebody who does what they want to do,
because they're not broke enough that they have to get a real job."
(Laughter)
But that's the work I'm doing, BioSentient Corporation,
trying to figure out: How do we integrate these things?
Let me finish by saying that my personal design issue for the future
is really about integrating;
to think about that intuitive and that analytical.
The arts and sciences are not separate.
High school physics lesson before you leave:
high school physics teacher used to hold up a ball.
She would say, "This ball has potential energy.
But nothing will happen to it, it can't do any work,
until I drop it and it changes states."
I like to think of ideas as potential energy.
They're really wonderful,
but nothing will happen until we risk putting them into action.
This conference is filled with wonderful ideas.
We're going to share lots of things with people.
But nothing's going to happen
until we risk putting those ideas into action.
We need to revitalize the arts and sciences today.
We need to take responsibility for the future.
We can't hide behind saying it's just for company profits,
or it's just a business,
or I'm an artist or an academician.
Here's how you judge what you're doing:
I talked about that balance between intuitive, analytical.
Fran Lebowitz, my favorite cynic,
said, "The three questions of greatest concern ..." --
now I'm going to add on to design --
"... are: Is it attractive?"
That's the intuitive.
"Is it amusing?" -- the analytical,
and, "Does it know its place?" -- the balance.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)